>> OH, SORRY.
>> JENNY.
>> REBECCA, HI.
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE BOTH BUYING DOG
FOOD TODAY.
>> WELL, NOT REALLY.
I'M BUYING BLUE RIVER DOG FOOD,
WHICH IS REAL FOOD WHICH MY
GUNTHER REALLY APPRECIATES.
RIGHT, BUDDY?
AND HAVE YOU EVER LOOKED AT THE
INGREDIENTS ON THAT BIG NAME
BRAND DOG FOOD YOU'RE BUYING?
>> IT SEEMED FINE TO ME.
>> REALLY?
OKAY.
WELL, THEN, WHY DON'T YOU READ
THEM OUT LOUD IN FRONT OF YOUR
DOG.
>> OKAY.
CORN, CHICKEN.
>> GO ON.
CONTINUE.
>> CORN GLUTEN MEAL.
>> SORRY, WHAT IS THAT "CORN
GLUTEN MEAL?"
>> NO, I THINK YOU HEARD ME.
>> HOW MUCH DO YOU PAY FOR BLUE
RIVER?
LIKE $80.
>> IT'S NOT $80, IT'S $73.99.
IT'S ACTUALLY ONLY 32 CENTS MORE
A DAY THAN YOU WHAT YOU PAY
MONTHLY.
>> NO, IT'S NOT.
>> ACTUALLY, IT IS.
IF YOU TAKE THE DIFFERENCE IN
THE PRICES BETWEEN THE TWO BAGS
AND DIVIDE THAT BY 28.
28 DAYS IN A MONTH, RIGHT?
7 DAYS IN A WEEK, CORRECT?
CORRECT?
>> CORRECT.
YOU AGREE.
>> I SHOULD BE GOING.
>> YEAH, OKAY.
28.
28 DAYS.
4 WEEKS IS A MONTH, RIGHT?
SO DIVIDE IT BY 28, WHICH WE
BOTH AGREED IS A MONTH.
>> YES.
>> IT COMES OUT TO 32 CENTS A
DAY MONTHLY.
>> I GUESS I WOULDN'T BE
BRAGGING ABOUT ALL THIS SAVINGS
BECAUSE IT IS NOT AS MUCH AS YOU
THINK.
>> NO, THAT MATH DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE.
>> OH, YOU DON'T THINK SO?
WELL, WHY DON'T WE ASK MY
HUSBAND.
DANIEL.
>> OH, MY GOD, I DON'T CARE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
YOU'RE NOT PLANNING ON FEEDING
THAT TO YOUR FUR BABY, ARE YOU?
>> SHE LIKES IT, OKAY?
AND I'M SAVING MONEY.
>> 32 CENTS A DAY MONTHLY?
THAT'S WORTH IT TO YOU?
FOR YOU DOG NOT TO BE ABLE TO
WALK?
>> OH, MY GOD.
THAT'S --
THAT'S WHY THE DOG HAS BEEN IN
THIS STUPID CART.
IT CAN'T WALK.
BECAUSE OF THE FOOD.
THE DOG HAS JUST BEEN SITTING
THERE IN THE CART AND LIKE I
THINK SUBCONSCIOUSLY I KNEW WHAT
THAT MEANT THE WHOLE TIME.
BUT I WASN'T EVEN READY TO SHOW
THAT TO MYSELF, TO SHOW ME THAT.
>> OKAY.
LOOK, SHE CAN WALK.
>> PEOPLE LIKE YOU SHOULD BE
HUNG IN A PUBLIC SQUARE.
>> LOOK AT ME.
I CAN FIX THIS.
>> I JUST FEEL LIKE THESE
ANIMALS HAVE NO VOICE.
WHO WILL BE THEIR VOICE?
>> YOU WILL.
REBECCA ANN BUSH, LOOK AT ME.
LOOK AT GUNTHER.
LOOK AT PRIME TIME.
LOOK AT WANTON.
LOOK AT ALEXANDER.
YOU ALWAYS, ALWAYS HAVE BEEN
THEIR ADVOCATES AND THEIR VOICE,
MORE THAN ANYONE, ANYONE WHO
EVER LIVED.
>> I KNOW.
I KNOW.
BUT I FEEL LIKE IT'S TOO LATE.
I MEAN, THE DOG CAN'T WALK.
IT IS JUST SITTING THERE
HUMILIATED.
>> IT WILL WALK IF IT STARTS
EATING BLUE RIVER TODAY.
NOW, FOR THE LOVE OF GOD, LOOK
YOUR DOG IN THE EYE AND LISTEN
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN YOUR LIFE.
>> FINE.
FELICITY, WHAT DO YOU WANT?
>> I WANT BLUE RIVER DOG FOOD,
MOMMA.
I WANT TO WALK.
IT'S ONLY 32 CENTS MORE A DAY.
MOMMY, I DON'T WANT A CORN
GLUTEN MEAL.
>> DO IT!
DO THE RIGHT THING!
IT'S NOT TOO LATE.
>> OH, MY GOD.
FINE.
I WILL BUY THE BLUE RIVER, OKAY?
MAY I GO NOW, PLEASE?
>> DEFINITELY.
>> WE JUST SAVED THAT DOG'S
LIFE.
>> NOT WE.
YOU.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE?
I THINK I'M READY TO DO IT.
I THINK I'M FINALLY READY TO
MAKE LOVE TO YOU.
>> WHAT?
IT'S WORKING?
>> IF THIS IS WHAT I THINK IT
IS, IT'S WORKING.
>> EVERYONE, HE SAYS IT'S
WORKING!
>> CONGRATULATIONS!
>> I CAN REALLY THANK YOU, YEAH.
>> BLUE RIVER DOG FOOD.
IF YOU WANT YOUR DOG TO EVER
WALK AGAIN.
♪♪